hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2014 I'm your host Annie
underwire delighted to be joined by the
gentleman from our head games Patrick
and Johanna nice to see you here to see
him pleasure I see you gentlemen you
were here with Helldivers this is a game
that's coming out later this year on ps3
ps4 and PlayStation Vita you've been
shopping it for a while now for the
folks who've never seen it before
explain that the overall grand concept
of what Helldivers is you want to take
it yeah sure
go for it so Helldivers is a fairly
hardcore top-down four-player
cooperative twin-stick shooter at night
you are four elite soldiers and you do
missions for the super earth government
to liberate humanity from the evil
threats of the universe and I've played
gay a lot of games like Alien Breed I
was really into when I was younger and
then they brought all the new alien
breeds out on the consoles last
generation and this is what I'm a purely
like physical level that's what I'm
touching into when I see this what is it
that makes Helldivers different in
relation to all those other games this
is quite at that space got a little
accreditor a while ago I mean for one
now I mean with old games that we make
we want to do a play on not just the
core mechanics of the game but the way
that the players interact while in
they're the they're called the comfort
of their home so Helldivers always has
friendly fire on it has a unique
mechanic which is called the stratagems
which you can call down from orbit at
any time so basically as hell about an
input a combination you can get our
strikes max we calls whatever and all of
these drops confer something to the team
and I mean even though you call
something down it's not necessarily
yours I can grab it or Patrick can grab
it and it creates for a really like yeah
what we call not hostile environment but
you know that you're kind of friendly a
hater
hit your friend on the shoulder kind of
like a brother brother versus brother
scenario yeah it took my gun yeah yeah
I like the the the lack of friendly fire
is an interesting one especially when
you're playing with four people under
these types of scenarios where often
you're try
to cover each other from multiple
directions and it really does work well
in Helldivers because you really need to
be careful what's on the other side of
what you're shooting at since I mean the
the entire core philosophy behind the
design is that you're humans humans are
squishy humans are if you have a huge
crustacean with a huge claws nipping at
you you're gonna lose an arm and another
arm in the head and that's usually a
pretty fatal outcome for the standard
sized human so mankind needs something
to be able to counter these UJA aliens
or or machines or whatever it is and
therefore they have extremely powerful
weapons that can bring these guys down
but what happens when you apply these
really powerful weapons on other humans
is some kind of general slaughter okay
that's way worse yes it's way worse that
and we're looking at the gameplay here
and you just explained the
moment-to-moment action because I feel
like that's sort of what the crux of a
game like this is yeah so so the guys
here they are they've just completed one
objective and they're gonna move on to
the next one
they're up against the cyborgs they need
to capture another area and activate and
defend two launch pads which are
basically nukes that they need to launch
on the enemy so the Helldiver
universe sort of is a weird one in in in
the sense that we accept the illogical
ways that sci-fi is portrayed so I mean
every mission ends with an extraction
and to bring people back from when when
they've been when they've fallen in
combat you Kastner stratagem which is
reinforced one and it dropped down from
orbit okay so when you get to the
extraction I mean if you want to make a
full extraction yes call in the new guy
and he drops down from orbit and he gets
it and you make sure you get more points
for that so I mean it makes no sense
from a logical perspective yeah but but
yeah video games we embrace that
did I see one of the characters was in a
mech suit or yes so our
that was a weird sort of design decision
we were apparently late in development
we were like wouldn't it be really cool
if we had vehicles in the game and yeah
that's what we did it just happened so
yeah you can't actually get your hands
on on vehicles like the MEK and we have
someone an unannounced once as well and
they sort of change the dynamic of the
game in in a way I mean they are
extremely more much more resilient they
are at a fixed speed and they couldn't
traverse difficult terrain as well which
is a big part of the game since the
environment environments player play a
key role and we call sort of allows you
traverse no order and stuff like that in
ways that the regular players want to do
and twice on Twitch or on Twitter is
asking is there different are you
travelling from planet to planet is
there an exploration aspect of it or is
it very much like instances where you're
going in is for people so you're
fighting a galactic war with everyone on
on this planet earth the real one and
you will travel to different sectors in
the universe and further the war effort
by fighting on different planets and
there are a couple of different
environments and different races that
you're fighting and each each planet
when it's completed will advance the
effort of the galactic war so the
missions themselves are fairly close
systems but you are always contributing
to to the main war effort
dude specific levels that have specific
types of terrain as it were they have
seven different enemies within those as
well yes so what happens is when you go
into the game you get to select or row
which warfront am i fighting on so you
get the bugs you get two cyborgs and
then we have a yellow unannounced
enemies pieces so you select which one
of those who want to fight you go into
the bugs and then there's the region
that is that you want to find and which
is sort of the active region where they
were the front line of the war is and
that's where every play every every
player in the world plays in the same
region so when I go into that region
isolate
one of the planets available there so I
I get provided I get selected for me I
like I've chosen for me like a variety
of planets it might be like a snow
planet a distant planet in a forest
planet and these have like varying
difficulties and also a stratagem reward
attention to them so you should select a
mission based on soar like difficulty
and and reward and also environment of
course so the snow levels are slightly
more challenging that's at one source or
the medium a forest or simpler versus
certain races and more about yeah we're
challenging to ours others so when
you've done that you are presented with
a couple of missions per planet and
these can vary from two to five missions
and when you completed all of those
missions your planet is completed and
that's then booked to the Galactic
backend okay I've done this and the your
influence or well mankind's everywhere
every player in the world's influence
over that region is slightly increased
and on the same side I mean that would
be a pretty one-way war if only man if
they were able to take regions so every
30 hours or so when quickness exactly in
the best way yet the enemy is pushed
back XO an event start which is you got
to defend new New York or something like
that and so that event is open for like
two hours and everyone everybody just
needs to get in and complete as many
missions as possible and a higher
mission
higher difficulty mission it's gonna
give a greater reward excellence but
it's gonna I mean it's the chances of
failing are bigger and and it's just
about completing a set limit all the
missions as well at some point very
connected sort of experience it seems to
be so to that end and is it very much a
you were logging in as one person and
then playing with three other random
people or are you gonna have some sort
of couch cooperative type thing yeah
we've got both of those so I mean it's
got a cross place so you can play I mean
the games gonna be available on ps4 ps3
and PS Vita
so if you've got a bead on a friend
gasps ps4 you can just come over to his
place and play on your Vita with them on
his ps4 or with ps3 on with ps4 or
whatever I mean any combination you can
think of and I mean the game is
important the mouths online co-op
excellent so the way this works is that
we're basically matchmaking people
together based on sort of their rank and
they're sort of standing so you're gonna
be matched with people sort of in the
same level as you are and you can
further enhance this by while in game
use a special stratagem that sort of
increases your matchmaking ranking or
matchmaking private priority so the
likeliness of other people joining your
game is even higher and of course for
those people that just want to play
single-player or you just want to play
locally with with just one other guy
there's a way to to set the privacy
modes for for the game as well awesome
Jonah Patrick thank you so much for
coming on shown as Helldivers for the
folks at home when is it coming out and
again on what platforms now it's it's
coming out this year and we're seeing ya
here this year this year this year I
almost promised awesome thank you much
for having us on guys enjoy your the
rest of your III